my name's Alex I'm data scientist at new
COO Inc which is a little company in
Redmond and I'm beginning to explore
deep learning applications and natural
language processing that's just one of
the one of the things that we're doing
there so I wanted to get people excited
about deep learning I'm pretty excited
about it it's pretty cool so I hope
everyone here today comes out with the
sense of enthusiasm and yes I can do
this and yeah so let's let's get started
as Alice said I've been using Python a
few years now
for all kinds of tasks everyday and I'm
at PI data so I realized I'm preaching
to the choir when I say that and
recently I've been diving more into some
of the Python libraries you can use for
deep learning so figured what better way
to tell people what I'm loving doing
then coming to PI data there's a bit of
a misconception out there I think that a
lot of people think you need to have big
so-called big data
whatever that means it seems like that
definition is always changing but you
really don't need big data in order to
do deep learning and I can go into an
example of that later where I train a
neural network on about two megabytes of
data with some pretty cool results so
yeah I just wanted to get that bad joke
out of the way so here's an introduction
to deep learning these four folks here
are some of the biggest figures in deep
learning up we've got Yamla cone on the
Left Geoff Hinton to the right of that
yoshua bengio to the right and I think a
lot of you will probably recognize
Andrew inge with his tongue slightly
sticking out on the right there I was
going to Google deep dream this but it
was way too frightening so I decided not
to talk to put it in the slides so what
is deep learning well let's start with
the basics here we know it's a subset of
machine learning and artificial
intelligence okay
yes artificial neural nets are inspired
by the brain but we're going to use them
to solve problems that we have
we're not gonna try to imitate the brain
per se that is its own kind of separate
thing and the deep refers to many many
layers and as we'll see they keep
getting deeper and deeper and deeper so
1957 let's go way back here almost 60
years Rosenblatt for the Cornell
Aeronautics laboratory decided he wanted
to learn about computer vision and so he
created this thing called the perceptron
which as you can see in this schematic
has a bunch of inputs which in his case
were pixels with weights associated to
them and a function that outputs some
sort of Y and this is a linear
classifier great but what's wrong with
linear classifiers
well linear classifiers work great with
this kind of problem where you can
linearly separate the classes but in the
case of a very simple logic problem like
X or you can't linearly separate the
data so what does this mean for the
perceptron what it means is that that
kind of perceptron that single layer
can't do a nonlinear do a nonlinear task
like X or so enter the multi-layer
perceptron this particular one has two
hidden layers but let's see here it was
proven that with one hidden layer you
can actually approximate any arbitrary
function and this is where all the math
nerds go whew arbitrary function
approximation yeah and if you want to
know more it has some things to do like
the Ries representation theorem and all
this other really fun math stuff but
basically what do we we don't care about
the math right now we care about solving
cool problems and you can use deep
neural nets for supervised learning
semi-supervised learning unsupervised
learning and reinforcement learning and
we can show examples of all those the
other really cool thing about deep
learning is that there
flexible architectural components so you
can basically take Lego boxes full of
blocks and look at examples of castles
and pirate ships and other things that
people have already made you can also
build your own and different Python
libraries have different strengths and
weaknesses in that this is the only
slide with math I'm going to show I
think there's a common conception for
deep learning that it's like super hard
and really really intensely mathematical
and yes there's some scary summation
notations and partial derivatives on
this but if you're comfortable with a
matrix and you're comfortable with first
quarter calc taking the chain rule then
deep learning is in the power of your
hands so just want to not have people
think that it's this like you need a PhD
to even start no no not not at all and
what's great about some of me of the
Python libraries is that all this is
done under the covers
you can configure it if you want but you
can also sort of abstract it away yeah
so what's going on on the left here is
just a diagram of the chain rule of this
function Z going through all the way
down to some other partials and on the
right hand side is a very specific very
specific representation of the back
propagation algorithm and the reason why
I'm mentioning this is because back prop
is how these deep neural nets learn by
taking a loss function and computing the
computing the derivatives of its of the
error function with respect to all of
the weights that go all the way down to
the very bottom and so basically what
happens is you have an error and you're
able to update all of the weights all
the way down and that's where the
learning happens so enough math what are
some of the cool applications of this
technology and what are some of the
tools common applications in computer
vision we
got classification tasks segmentation so
you've got a photograph of a motorcycle
in a car and a dog and a cat being able
to sort of draw boxes around each of
those and label them properly
obviously there's facial recognition
with Facebook we see this working pretty
well you click on someone's face and if
it's a friend that you're you're friends
with it's probably going to be that
person's name right at the top natural
language processing has some cool
applications to this so you've use
Cortana or Siri before in Google now you
know that they're doing ASR but what you
might not know is the the speech
recognition is using deep neural
networks for for that task
there's also machine translation sort of
like universal translator I've seen some
cool things coming out I think of
Microsoft with the the Skype kind of
real-time translation which is really
really amazing and then later on natural
language understanding being able to
take a a series of you know blog posts
or news articles and being able to
answer questions about them this is
really really interesting stuff so I
wanted to talk about some tools and I'll
go into a couple examples later but
these are the most common tools used in
deep learning a torch is particularly
hot right now no pun intended
it's it's mostly being used and
developed by the folks at Facebook NYU
and google deepmind this is a great tool
it's not a Python tool I know we're at
PI data but I highly recommend it
the syntax isn't is you're not too
unfamiliar for someone who's used to
Python so definitely worth checking out
it's a really active area right now if
you're just getting started Cafe is also
really excellent they have what they
call their model zoo where you can
download and install pre-trained models
that are all the reference models from
like the Google deep dreamwork
handwritten digit work that was done in
the 1980s when you're using an 8
and it recognizes how many dollars are
on that check that you want to cash etc
so that's a great way to get out of the
box ready to go tools to apply for your
application Theano is another really
good one this one is a little bit lower
level so if you're really really
interested in the lower level technical
things going on and how how your how
your neural net is interfacing with you
know the computer hardware and your you
know graphics card if you want to do
some computations against that which I
highly recommend theano is definitely
for you now it's really sophisticated
and kind of hard to use so I wouldn't
recommend it if you're not interested in
those lower level things but just know
that there is a whole host of active
development right now on top of it all
Python tools PI learn and lasagna are
two great examples of that and there's
good documentation for those a couple
more I want to plan out graphlab create
is a really great tool to get started
with deep learning they have a really
good intelligent sane defaults if you
want to create a neural net from a piece
of data and that's a great way to get
started because if you don't know what
the layer types are that you want or you
know exactly what it is you're doing in
terms of tuning hyper parameters you
know definitely check those guys out
yeah that's a great tool and then lastly
two other things I want to mention neon
and deep learning 4j neon has Python
bindings and I think that deep learning
for J is going to because those folks
are going to get it to run on spark and
of course we have PI spark and I think
that that has a lot of potential so keep
your eye out on those two so let's
really quickly run through some
different network topologies so we've
seen some tools we've seen some cool
problems what are some of the different
sort of hierarchical structures we can
use to solve these problems one of the
most common ones is what's called a
convolutional neural net
and I'm gonna give kind of a conceptual
example of what that looks like on the
next slide but these were created in the
80s by Jelena Khan and these were
famously what was used for some of the
classic handwriting recognition tasks
that I mentioned a little bit earlier
they've had a little bit of a
renaissance in 2012 with the image net
competition a few researchers out of
utoronto khrushchev ski and Hinton and
I'm forgetting the third guy they beat
the pants off of all previous attempts
and computer vision has classically been
done with handcrafted features that have
been incrementally improved over decades
so the fact that they were able to enter
this competition and win by such a wide
margin has really kind of this is kind
of a watershed moment in deep learning
and for convolutional neural nets and
then it's not just used for images you
can also use these for text one of the
cool things about the deep neural Nets
in general is that they're usually
applicable to lots of different problem
domains so you can reshare a lot of the
same knowledge so what is a convolution
I'm not going to go into the mathematics
too much but here's sort of a conceptual
example one way to think of it is kind
of like you can think of it maybe like a
two-dimensional version of reduce so
you're going over this this yellow patch
here is going over those nine those nine
green squares and computing some sort of
some sort of function with those ones
and zeros and it's just adding them up
and placing them in that smaller nine by
nine pink matrix on the right and so
what this is doing is that's abstracting
the features as you go up the neural
network so that's kind of conceptual
happy to talk about that more later this
is a picture of what one of these deep
neural nets looks like this is a picture
of the one I mentioned called
Alec's net that one imagenet in 2012 and
what it does here
it takes a photo of a kitten and the
kitten gets resized a little bit and
stretched and the first filter here is
sort of like edges
it's abstracting away in convolving
those raw pixels into combinations of
pixels like edges after that it's being
convolve de ghin and you're building
combinations of edges maybe that was her
corners on and on and on creating
combinations of corners like polygons
and more abstract concepts eventually
getting to very abstract concepts like
eyes ears noses whiskers and finally at
the end you get a cat so that's kind of
a very conceptual conceptual definition
of what's going on and again this
network beat the pants off of all
previous attempts at classifying images
in this data set so that's pretty
amazing and just just to give a little
more info here you see some numbers on
here so the size of the last layer here
near the kitten is the number of classes
in this particular task and what's
happening is the last layer takes all of
that abstraction and richness that it's
learned as you've sent an image through
and it outputs its vote of confidence as
to which class it thinks is the most
likely that that image belongs to so in
other words that class is the one with
the highest likelihood and in this case
it's cat here's an example of a few of
the images that were classified with
Alex net and you can see that it's most
of the time it's pretty spot-on with
some of the ones that it gets right but
sometimes sometimes it's not so red here
indicates where it's classified it
correctly and when red is not on top
that means that it missed out here so it
got mushroom wrong it got tumble dryer
wrong
but all these other ones are are right
and what's amazing is that there are a
thousand different categories in this
imagenet competition so this is a very
very general general deep neural net in
terms of its ability to classify images
which is really cool so who hears heard
of Google deep dream awesome here's a
photo of Kerry Park want to make a plug
for Seattle so let's send it through
Google Nets deep dream code and feed the
output back in a few times and see what
happens well that's kind of freaky Wow
who wants to see a live demo of deep
dreaming alright let's do it
so I'm not gonna go line by line here
because this isn't in tutorial but
basically what I'm doing is taking
taking the code in cafe and importing it
into the right places there's also a
little bit of code that Google has going
on here in the background and what I'm
doing is I'm loading in Oh No
Oh Oh sad let's see let's try this one
more time all right I'm just gonna go
straight down to let's just load
everything above here yeah let's do that
did it today all right sweet so I'm
gonna take a blank image you're seeing
it it's just a white square and let's
yeah all right sweet so we've got our
white square let's see what Google comes
up with so that integer that's
incrementing in the bottom is the layer
that it's gone through and there are 39
layers in this particular Network so
what you're seeing is deep dream
dreaming from nothing just pretty cool
what you can also do is filter out the
the kinds of kinds of dreaming you want
it to do so this one it's kind of only
dreaming at the lower levels which are
more lines and edges and you can see
this kind of gives what people have been
calling sort of an impressionistic
effect and in in cafe 2 you can take a
look at the different layer types etc
cafe is a really wonderful tool to use
in Python and another thing you can do
is why not take the freaky output and
then feed it back into Google again
that's how I generated those Kerry Park
images I sent it all the way through and
then you put that output back in as the
new input and keep dreaming and dreaming
and dreaming over and over again and so
they there's a nice little just for loop
here that you can use and this is just
the Google deep gene code on github this
I didn't write this code so it's really
easy to install and pretty pretty fun
anyone who's been following politics
lately whether it's the euro stuff with
Greece or whether it's the you know
presidential races here has seen
probably pretty funny images of
politicians lately so definitely
recommend checking this out cool let's
go back
so this is a picture of the schematic of
that particular neural net and notice
how much deeper it is then Alec's net
this one's 39 layers so it's more than
three times as deep as imagenet and
we're seeing that these are getting
deeper and deeper as we have cheaper and
cheaper and more computing power and
also as companies like Google and
Facebook are investing in investing in
getting the distributed stuff right
that's where like this power really
comes in it's really awesome
another kind of neural net is called a
recurrent neural network these are
really cool because they're really good
at learning sequences in other words any
kind of abstract sequence like time
series data works really well text works
really well you can think of natural
language is a kind of time series of
characters or words and there are a few
really well-known varieties I'm not
going to go into that too much but just
just know that they're there one of the
ones I'm going to show you is what's
called a long short-term memory Network
and this slide here is just an example
of some of the different relationships
you can have between layers so the
reason that this is really important is
that with like a convolutional neural
network you only have feed-forward
connections where any of the units in a
given layer only only have outputs going
upwards to the next highest layer
whereas with recurrent neural networks
you can have all of these different
relationships between layers which makes
it a lot more complicated and also makes
the feature sorry the sort of function
approximation a lot more rich in terms
of what you can model with these kinds
of networks so that's pretty cool
everyone with me so far
awesome okay who's here - heard of word
- Veck cool so if for those who don't
know a word - Veck is a really cool body
of code and work that came out of Google
a couple years ago
what they did is they trained a huge
neural net on a bunch of data and
embedded words into 300 dimensional
space and what they found with that is
some pretty cool semantic stuff so it
kind of looks like this you take a
sentence and there's a little bit of a
schema here and it maps all of these
things together so just to give a really
cool down-to-earth example this is word
to Veck with pca down to two dimensions
so that we can all enjoy it together on
the screen here and what we're seeing is
a really kind of amazing thing we have a
bunch of countries on the left and their
capital is all on the right and what we
can kind of notice is that the sort of
euclidean distance in this this space is
kind of roughly equal between countries
and capitals across all of them but I
think what's even more interesting is
not only our countries and capital sort
of equidistant from each other but you
also see sort of some common sense
knowledge being embedded in here - like
for example notice how China Russia and
Japan are much closer to each other than
say China and Russia and Japan are -
Spain Portugal and Greece
so that's geographic knowledge kind of
being embedded in this 300 dimensional
space so we're to have actually great
for natural language applications
particularly if you're trying to work
with getting some sort of semantic data
out so semantic sentiment analysis
things like that highly we would
recommend checking this out and it's all
it's all open source now I want to talk
about using recurrent neural nets for
modeling text so one of my favorite
books in the world is Ulysses and what I
wanted to do was teach a recurrent
neural net how to write like James Joyce
that just that just makes me so excited
so
I took the text of Ulysses which you can
get on gutenberg and i took out some of
the gutten project gutenberg boilerplate
so that it started famously with the
first sentence of Ulysses and ends with
yes I said yes I will yes so what
happens when I put this through a
recurrent neural net some pretty crazy
things this is less than two megabytes
of data and what I can do after roughly
seventeen passes through this two
megabyte data set is generate the
following text and this is the text that
had the lowest the lowest validation
error so I know Ulysses is kind of a
tough example because Joyce is an
infuriating writer he has lots of
wordplay and intentionally confuses you
and tries to be funny all the time so
this is like hard example for training a
worker and they're on that right but
when you take a look at it there's some
pretty complex things going on here for
one it learns punctuation it's already
understanding prepositional phrases here
it understands a lot of formatting this
example doesn't really give it justice
but at this point it's already learning
different kind of markdown formatting
like underlining parentheses brackets
etc and in natural links processing
that's kind of a big deal because one of
the issues with being able to accurately
model parentheses is that you know you
have variable lengths involved and the
fact that there's enough state in this
recurrent neural net for it to sort of
know when to close up a paren is pretty
astounding and so there's a lot of
active research in this area right now
to apply this to the real world so one
of the things I'm working on next is
trying to do this with music I want to
teach a recurrent neural net how to make
music like Beethoven so strong AI is
coming incident
didn't another cool kind of network
architecture is what's called a
recursive neural tensor what network is
if that's not enough of a mouthful
sometimes you're called RN ends but it
gets really confusing because there we
have the other kind of RN n already so I
wouldn't call these RN ends if you can
help it
one of the things that these are really
great for is scene parsing I'm just
gonna go to the next slide here so take
a photograph this is an image from
Stanford and it's an image of a group of
what looked like humans congregating
outside some sort of building and
there's a tree I'm not really sure it's
going on but you know I'm gonna train a
neural network to find out for me and
what's cool about this particular
architecture is it takes advantage of
sort of the recursive nature of language
and it builds up hierarchical
hierarchical structures that sort of
describe scene imagery just as you can
see here up top its parsing the scene
image into constituent parts and
breaking it down so all those things
combined together kind of add up to the
whole and the same thing this this
bottom part of the slide is looks like a
parse tree for a sentence and these
networks are sort of at this
intersection of images and language so
combining those together is really cool
and there's great work coming out of
Stanford on this stuff it's not all
supervised learning
there's also unsupervised learning with
deep neural nets there was a group of
researchers out of Google who taught a
deep neural net to recognize faces
without any labelled data which is
pretty astounding because in 2012 the
Alex net had an error rate of about 15%
16% 17% so with this unsupervised data
they put 10 million frames of YouTube
videos into a deep neural net of
what are called auto-encoders and here's
what they came up with this is pretty
astounding this thing can recognize
human faces and cat faces in a pretty
statistically significant way without
having had any training and I'm sorry
not training data but without any labels
on this data and if you want to see what
it thinks a human and a cat look like
you're in for in for a treat these are
representations of the quote unquote
optimal stimulus with respect to doing a
little bit of numerical constraint
optimization and this is what they are
basically in in English they're saying
that this is sort of the the image that
sort of maximizes what that that
particular unit thinks of as being a
face so you can think that that's the
face human face neuron and on the right
same thing with cats so again this is
all on unsupervised this is an
unsupervised task with no labels pretty
astounding another kind of learning I
want to mention is called transfer
learning and this is really an old idea
but was recently explored with deep
neural Nets
in 2014 what this group of researchers
did is they took Alex net the one from
2012 and they did the following they got
some data and they trained Alex net on
image net data what they then did is
they propagated on-the-scene data that
image that had never seen before just
think of it like a test dataset a cut
off the propagation of those images
through the network at a certain point
and what they did is they extracted the
output from those layers as vectors so
for example in Alex net some of the last
some of the last fully connected layers
have 4096 units
so what'd you get if you stopped Alex
net is a 4096 dimensional array of
features and these features are very
abstract and high-level so just this
last Tuesday I was down in San Francisco
giving a presentation with a couple of
folks at dado and what we did is we
built an image similarity service and
what we did was take a pre trained
neural net and we propagated unseen
images of dresses through it and what we
were able to do was cut off these
dresses as we were sending them through
the net extract their features and then
we compared them in an unsupervised way
by just taking their Euclidean distance
in this space and this is a little bit
abstract so I'm gonna show you what this
looks like when everything is up and
running but basically the idea here is
you don't need to train a neural net for
every data set you can take one that's
pre trained like Alex net on a very
general data set like image net and use
it for your own specific application so
let's take a look at what an image
similarity application might look like
and if you any of you were here for
Peter Tedder walks talked yesterday you
probably saw this in action so what I'm
gonna do is I'm gonna take a dress we're
gonna take this blue one here and what
we're gonna do is we're gonna find the
nearest neighbors to it so here I've
already before this demo started I've
extracted the features from all of my
dresses and now I'm going to compare
them great now let's take a look at the
ten nearest neighbors to our blue dress
so again imagenet I'm sorry Alex net had
never seen these dresses before but its
general features were trained on the
image net data set and with this we're
able to compare all of these images to
each other and I think it's pretty
astounding how good a job it does at
least with this particular example so
that's an example of transfer learning
highly recommend doing that if you're
just getting started
did you have a question yeah yes so the
question is do you need to match the
pixel sizes for these different images
and in this example the answer to that
is yes
Alex net takes in images of 256 by 256
course dude training your own network
you can decide what input you want but
what but what we did here is we took
original JPEG images resize them to 256
by 256 and then put them through alex
net because alex net was already trained
awesome so another kind of deep learning
is called reinforcement learning and who
here has seen some of the Atari game
stuff coming out of google deepmind so
what these folks did is just using
pixels only in the game score they
trained what they call their deep cue
network to learn 49 different games and
they achieved professional game tester
accuracy so here's a little gift of that
and again it just kept playing this over
and over and over again same algorithm
same net same hyper parameters but they
beat the pants off of all previous
attempts at doing reinforcement learning
against the set of Atari games that they
played against
a couple extra things I want to mention
a lot of people talk about visualization
when they talk about deep neural nets so
I want to say that this doesn't give any
intuition at all about what's going on
this is really abstract this is not
helpful at all so there are some great
Python tools to help you visualize
what's going on at different layers and
one of the tools I'd really recommend
for that is cafe in fact it's so
excellent they even have an eye -
notebook that goes through the steps of
visualizing images as you send them
through a deep neural net so it's great
for getting intuition and it's great
just kind of for for seeing the
transformations that are happening and
here are a couple I'm just going to go
up the network here so as you saw you
can go back so we're starting with these
images on the left and if you look at
the bottom that indicates the layer that
we're sort of abstracting up and as we
go through the net we're getting
increasingly abstract as things go along
until the very end now this is where I
go this doesn't make any sense to me and
that's where I dive into the math and I
say oh now I get it it makes so much
more sense and out comes the doc
we've still got a lot of learning to do
there are some Pitt major pitfalls to
describe in deep learning but suffice to
say these are things that actually our
knowledge of improves deep learning for
example you know these models are hard
to interpret they're counterintuitive
but one of the things we can do to make
them better is fool them and I'm running
out of time so I'm not going to go into
it too much but by training these
networks against examples that are
generated intentionally to trick them
you make them much stronger so here
we've seen some different applications
of deep learning we've seen a bunch of
cool tools both pythonic and not and
we've seen that the power is really in
your hands to apply these to your own
problems and if you want to dive into
the literature or dive into books
there's some great resources for that
I'm happy to take questions yeah that's
just a brief overview thanks everyone so
much thanks
love to open up the floor for questions
now yes
the sins no I'm not so so the question
is am i using the multi-class classifier
for getting the image similarity and the
answer is no we're we're not propagating
the images through to that last layer
that we're taking all of the all of the
features that go into that last layer
that that last layer kind of boils away
into being a single class label and
we're taking that rich 4096 dimensional
vector as our input into our image
similarity thing so we're not we're not
using the the thousand yes exactly and
it doesn't have to be the last layer
either if that might be not abstract
enough you can actually extract your
features earlier than that in the
process it well it relates to it I gave
this that presentation on Tuesday just
using their software and it's really
easy to use if they've got the network
built into the software and it's a
really simple API unlike some of the
other Python tools like Theano and and
pi learn graph hub creators a really
simple awesome intuitive API you can use
to do that so that that's why I use them
for that particular example more
questions yeah yeah
yes there is a library called character
RNN CH AR - RNN I'm happy to you know
talk offline - if you want but it's a
torch package it's really easy to
install and you're basically just
running it on the command line yeah yeah
I couldn't quite hear you on the
parameter names um we should talk
offline yeah any any additional
questions all right thanks so much yes
we'll share the slides great